Today I want to talk about
my struggles with Korean.
I want to talk a bit about how I
have learned different languages,
what the process has been for
me, where I have had success and
why, and where I have struggled.
Some of the languages that I
have struggled in include Korean,
Arabic, and I'm going to go into why.
Today I'm gonna talk about Korean.
My initial exposure
to Korean was in 1972.
That's a long time ago.
My wife and I were living in Japan.
We went to Korea on a
visit just to see it.
I was very interested in a
country on the continent of Asia
with some kind of language relationship
to Japanese in terms of being of North
Asia origin in its basic structure, an agglutinative
language, and, of course, with
an awful lot of boring from Chinese in
the case of both Korean and Japanese.
And of course, tremendous
cultural borrowing from China.
So I was very interested.
Had a great visit when Korea was,
I guess, considered a developing
country, but it was really developing
as we now know. I went again in 1976.
A good friend was at the
Canadian Embassy there.
He was getting married.
He wanted me to be best
man at his wedding.
He married a Korean lady, so I did that.
At that time, I bought some books for
learning Korean, and I'm gonna show you
my library of books for learning Korean.
Yeah, but I didn't do much with it.
I went back to Japan, where
again, I was living at the time.
And then in 1980 I visited Korea.
I was working for Atomic Energy of Canada.
I thought I was gonna be very much
involved with Korea because Canada
was building a nuclear reactor in Korea.
But in the end, I only spent one
year with Atomic Energy of Canada.
Then I went back to the forest industry.
And so again, my initial sort of spurt
of Korean study kind of went down the
tubes, but still it was out there.
And then, you may know that in 2003
I wrote my book, The Linguist, about my
experiences in Learning nine Languages,
which at that time, didn't include
Korean, and then we got started with LingQ.
At any rate, I said, "You know
what? I should get back to Korean!"
So I bought some more books.
We didn't have Korean at LingQ. One
book, which was very good, which I
really enjoyed was the Introduction
to Korean, I think it's called.
You'll see when I'll show
you my library. Done here at the
University of British Columbia.
The narrators'
voices were so good, and
that's so important in any
kind of learning material.
You can't have these beginner books with
a boring narrator. It just turns me off.
And that was kind of the high
point of my enthusiasm for Korean.
Also, the book was full of patterns.
Language learning is about patterns.
They had grammatical explanations, they
had terms like copulative verbs. Strange.
But I ignored all those explanations.
I just
accepted the patterns, listened to the
patterns, listened to the dialogues,
which were kind of semi-humorous
dialogues. Students situations that I
was kind of more or less familiar with.
Not too heavy on the sort of cultural
traditions and that kind of thing,
which is more difficult because they're
less familiar. And that was kind
of, as I say, the high point of
my enthusiasm for learning Korean.
So I bought more books, but more and
more of these books, they were all so boring.
And so I started losing interest.
And at that time, instead I became
interested in Russian and we had
Russian at LingQ. And pretty soon Korean
was in the rear view mirror and I
was spending all my time on Russian.
I spent a lot of time on Russian.
There was very interesting content,
political content, literature,
audio books, so much good content.
We had it at LingQ and so I was off with
learning Russian. And then
Czech and then other languages.
Although I have made regular attempts
to sort of restart my Korean, and
you'll see here when I show you my
statistics that 2010 at various times
I've said, "Okay, I should put in three
months, you know, a 90-day challenge."
See what I can do to get my
Korean up to a better level.
And I think I have improved.
Or did improve, but then of course I
didn't use it for the longest time.
I'll show you a video at the end here
of me speaking Korean with my tutor
after one of my 90-day challenges.
But still, it was difficult at
LingQ for a variety of reasons.
You know, we had some beginner content.
We didn't have the Mini Stories.
The intermediate content
was quite uninteresting.
What I attempted to do
was find podcasts. And then I actually paid
someone to transcribe these podcasts so
that I could work my way through these.
But they were very difficult.
One was a literary podcast,
the other was a political podcast.
I just fought my way through these.
It was so hard.
So many unknown words.
And of course in Korean there's so many
little words that have eight possible
meanings and I didn't know which meaning
was appropriate, and we didn't yet have
Sentence View as we now have, where I
could get a sentence translation, which
would help me decide which of the sort of
translations of that word was accurate.
I'll show you how I go through Korean
on LingQ today, and you'll see that.
There are more sort of user hints from
other users who have looked up words
and I can quickly see the most likely
translation of a word and looking
at the sentence, meaning I can get
a better sense of what it means.
None of that was available before.
LingQ was slow, slower before, it
was just hard going. So there were
too many headwinds.
It was just too difficult.
So I was always attracted
away to something else.
So, you know, again, thinking back to
that sort of high point of my enthusiasm
for Korean, there is that quotation
from Shakespeare's Julius Caesar where
Brutus says, "There is a tide in the
affairs of men, which if taken at the
flood, will lead to success," or something.
So if I had continued when I was most
enthusiastic, and if I had had less
difficulty, or if there had been more
interesting content available, or
if LingQ had worked better, or if the
dictionaries were better, if all of
these conditions, if the attraction
had been greater and the resistance
had been less, then I think I would've
continued and achieved a better level.
However, all the effort that I
have put into Korean is not lost.
I have, according to my statistics,
some 40-, 50,000 known words,
which theoretically is a lot.
Now, in all of these languages,
it depends on how we count words.
There are a lot of different
endings to words in Korean that,
you know, help define the function
of the word in a sentence.
So it's not something we can compare
to other languages. But I have a large
base of, you know, vocabulary.
And even of comprehension. And my Chinese
helps, of course. So that if I were to go
to Korea...but I don't have the freedom.
I have a family.
I have other things that I'm doing.
I can't just go off to Korea for
two months and be with people
and speak Korean all the time.
But if I were to do that, I think I
could bring it up to a decent level.
Nevertheless, I am disappointed.
I feel that, you know, having
first bought books for Korean back
in 1973, so that's a long time.
I've had those books a long time.
I've put a lot of effort into Korean.
If I were to open up some of these books
that are on my bookshelf, you'll see
that there's underlinings and tick marks
and all kinds of things, but you know,
you need to have meaningful, interesting
content that you can stay with.
Which I have for Persian right now. That
you're not deliberately trying to learn.
I was too much deliberately
trying to learn the language
rather than enjoying the language.
Once you get to where you can
enjoy the language, even if the
progress is slow, it's enjoyable.
I got to where the Korean
wasn't enjoyable, it was work.
And when it's work, you know, I
find that it's harder to commit the
time necessary to be successful.
So I'm gonna end up here with showing
you me working on Korean at LingQ.
And also after that you'll see a
video, as I say, of a conversation
I had about nine years ago after
one of my 90-day challenges.
So I haven't given up on Korean, but it's
been a long time and I haven't achieved
what I would have liked to have achieved.
Thanks for listening.
Bye for now.
Yeah, I just wanna show you, you
know, how I study on LingQ here.
I'm going to use the computer version.
I could also do it on my iPad.
You can see here that our Korean page has
improved tremendously, so we now have so
much content here to choose from. Literary,
audio books, ab workout, you
know, all kinds of different stuff.
Getting started, you know, we have our
Mini Stories, which we never had before.
To that extent, it's a lot better.
I can even select the level that I want
to be looking at in terms of content.
But I'll give you an example.
So here's this thing I found.
This is imported from YouTube.
We now have the ability to
import things from YouTube,
which wasn't the case before.
So here's a lesson that
I found in our library.
I could have gone to YouTube to
find it myself, but at any rate,
so I can click on this thing.
Okay.
So it's kind of childish, but
something I might do. Okay, if I go here.
So I can listen to the audio
just for that sentence.
I can look up individual words, which I
could do before, but it's much faster.
So I have all these different
meanings, with the most likely
one up at the top. Show translation.
Now, if it becomes more of
a sentence, you'll see here.
So this is not exactly fascinating
content, but it just shows you
how LingQ has improved with the
introduction of, you know,
the ability to import content.
And I'm gonna show you
this, but you can see that you
can import MP3 files, eBooks,
lessons, so I can bring material in.
If I import an Audio Transcribe, the
Whisper AI will give me a transcript
so that I will create a lesson from it.
So there's so many different types of
content that I can use that the whole
experience has become much more agreeable.
If I go to a website like Chosun Ilbo
here, and they've had floods in Korea,
and if I pick an article about the
floods like this one, and I go to our
web browser, our browser extension, and
I can import it. And it'll come into
LingQ so I can study it as a lesson.
All right, we'll just wait a
few seconds while it comes in.
And I... one of the things that has
changed compared to previously is the
tremendous availability of things that
I can import with a click, using our
browser extension. From YouTube, from
articles in newspapers, and so forth.
I open up the lesson.
I have a lesson.
All right.
You'll notice that there
is a lot of blue text.
These are unknown words.
I have about 13,000 words, known
words in Persian, and if I go import
something into LingQ, you will
see that there are far fewer new
words, having spent far less time on
Persian, I understand much more of it.
Look at this.
There are just two blue words here.
You can see that in the case of
Persian, you know, if I go to
my all time numbers here, I've been at
it since 2018 and kind of like a peak
known words addition is like 1,000.
And that's a peak most of the time.
It's quite a bit less than that.
If I go and look at my Korean situation,
despite the amount of time that I spent
on it, you know, and, and you can see
it goes back to 2010, and there are days
where I hit like 4,000 known words added.
Now I'm helped by the fact that
I know Chinese, and so I can plow
forward in Korean. And I will add
more and more known words, but
it'll still be difficult for me.
So I have this greater sense of
just working and working and not
getting anywhere in Korean,
as opposed to in Persian